[Music]
kathy is with us in grand rapids
michigan hi kathy how are you
i'm good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
um so
i have been through financial peace
university a couple times i've
snowballed myself down to
mortgage payment and student loan
payment student loans will be paid off
for public loan forgiveness in about two
years
my mortgage payment is a 3.1 per 25
interest i have about 80 000 left on
that
um
had to get a different vehicle
and this is kind of where the question
starts coming in so just because of
timing and how it worked out and being
out of town and no cars available
i had intended to use some of
forty five thousand dollars i had saved
to get a new vehicle
i didn't know how i was going to piece
it together but long story short what i
ended up with
was
an auto loan of about 41 000 at 3.99
percent interest that was by mistake i
know i can get a better rate than that
so i'm trying to get in to
refinance that auto loan but then my
questions come in is that really like
what should i do with this 45 000 i have
saved i i'm 55 i only have 25 000 in
mutual funds for retirement
what is your household income
um well that just jumped so it was at 56
000 and then in august it went up to
104.
okay
so i guess you're gonna have to go back
through financial peace university you
flunked
i did with that car thing
horribly yeah you did
and then you just called and asked me
how to refinance a car debt and keep the
car debt while you have the money in the
bank to pay it off
you just did that my
like what real like i really want to
know what's the best thing to do like i
do have the money you know what the best
thing to do is you went through the
class twice
but then i have nothing like i don't
because you bought a car you can't
afford left
yeah okay yeah yeah that's one of the
things i've been wondering is if i just
need well here's the thing if you if you
use your 45 000 to become debt-free
other than your student loan
which is another problem by the way did
you know that 2
of the public student loan forgiveness
people actually get it forgiven 98
percent of not
yeah no i didn't know that so i don't
have a lot of hope for your plan
um how much student loan debt have you
got
um there's 69 000 left okay
all right
so they did recently you can do what you
want to do and obviously you regularly
do that
um so here's what i would tell you to do
okay and this is going to be very
consistent with everything that i taught
you in that class okay okay we're going
to walk the baby steps
you have a hundred thousand dollars in
debt
40 of it is a car
69 is a student loan and you have forty
five thousand dollars in the bank you
have a car you can't afford you need to
sell your car
you need to take ten thousand dollars of
the forty five thousand and go buy you a
ten thousand dollar car
and then you need to use the rest of the
money and pay it on a student loan and
then you need to get on a debt snowball
beans and rice rice and beans on a debt
on a budget where you don't have any
life until you get the student loan paid
off because the federal private student
loan forgiveness program
is an absolute scam i just gave you the
real numbers
98
are not forgiven
two percent have that equals a lot of
people who bet
on the government keeping their word and
they were lied to and you're one of them
if i woke up in your shoes i would treat
that student loan like it was a cancer
and i would pay it off really really
fast i'll get rid of the car and undo
the mistake that i made there
probably got to write a check to do that
gotta help you a little stupid tax check
there
and then um
you move on from there now you get that
student loan paid off then you build
your emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses and then you start
investing 15
of your household income which in your
case will be 15 000 a year 16 000 a year
until you get your home paid off you're
going to do all of this by the time
you're 60
and and then you're probably going to
have your house paid off shortly after
that if you'll stay
on a plan
and quit losing your mind and driving
the car in the ditch no pun intended
so um but this is what people do and we
all do it we all make mistakes you made
a mistake now you've got a choice are
you gonna are you gonna double down
i'm gonna keep that car well you can you
keep the car that's fine
it's your decision you're like a grown
woman and stuff
so but you call me and made the mistake
of asking me what i would do and then i
am duty-bound to tell you
again
what i would do